[Música]
o que é a saúde
conforme os funcionários mais antigos
saúde é não ser doente e não tem nenhuma
doença mas também é a garantia de que o
poder público vai prestar esse
atendimento a casos o doente então ser
feliz é não ser doente ou se alguma
coisa de ruim acontecer teremos lá o
estado a prestar atendimento e
conseqüentemente veremos em segurança
será que é isso apenas isso pra mim ser
ter saúde é ter escolha é ter liberdade
porque andando por aqui hoje
as pessoas que me olharam olhar um pouco
de estranhamento
talvez pelo mau gosto do painel do
avental para quem tinha um microfone que
denunciava que a falar ou então quem
sabe
pensando ela não tinha roupa
na verdade eu queria muito me sentir
como a minha amiga nos últimos dias de
vida que morreu semana passada se sente
usando esse avental de doente
só que eu não consegui mesmo desfilando
entre vocês todos aqui porque eu estou
bem e me sinto bem e eu tenho liberdade
e mesmo tem uma roupa por trás que não
vai deixar minha bunda de fora que esse
eventual normalmente é o que acontece
com ele
quando a gente usa no hospital essa
escolha é uma escolha que nos garante a
liberdade de quem está doente não tem
mas faremos aqui entre nós um acordo e
semântico do que a final é ser doente da
aas várias hipóteses que essa expressão
que é uma expressão polissêmica traduz é
preciso que a gente aqui fique pra nós
a definição de que ser doente pode ser o
acometimento de uma de uma síndrome rara
de uma doença
catastrófica como é o câncer mas também
de uma doença infecto como é a dengue a
dengue que no paraguai tem o mesmo nome
e que através de um telefonema recebi a
notícia de que meu filho mãe eu tenho
dele e eu fiquei pensando será que o
mosquito do paraguai igual ao nosso
será que o sintoma é o mesmo e fiquei
muito feliz quando eu soube que ele
tinha cometido de dengue que era uma
notícia péssima uma doença séria mas que
lá em assunção avião-hospital
especificamente vocacionado para doenças
dessa natureza chamadas doenças
tropicais
se não se deu conta da prevenção que era
a primeira fonte de garantia de
segurança que nós tínhamos de que o
estado tomar tal tomada pra conta da sua
parte para que isso não aconteça
ao menos se tenha a segunda parte que
ele ter um aparato suficiente pra que
ainda que depois de quatro cinco horas
de espera se deu atendimento de um soro
que é fundamental para que a pessoa não
venha a óbito
então além da perspectiva individual da
roupa da escolha ou do que é uma doença
mas também temos apenas perspectiva do
ponto de vista do estado
afinal nós temos a garantia ou não de
que esse estado não socorrerá se em
algum momento de nossa vida fica
ficaremos doentes e sabemos disso e
mesmo que não acometidos de doenças
sérias percorreremos hospitais
laboratórios e nos transformaremos em
pessoas idênticas com essas com essas
roupinhas não tão bonitas
o certo é que a saúde de uma certa forma
passa pela perspectiva de que o estado
terá recursos para aplicá-los em saúde
então numa perspectiva econômica essa
segurança só dá é dada sociedade a
partir do quanto de capital de quanto
investimento nós tenhamos em área de
saúde no brasil nós temos o sus
o tema único de saúde brasileiro é
considerada o número de população o
maior do mundo
ele contém em si mas os ditames
constitucionais baseados em duas ideias
fundamentais uma de integralidade e uma
de universalidade integralidade
significa que o atendimento à saúde
qualquer que seja ela de exames a
internações será feito por todos os
entes da federação união estado
município universalidade a todos então
por todos ea todos
isso é o que preconiza a nossa
constituição para tanto a constituição
já garante o cidadão que ele tivesse a
prestação de serviços à estatal no
entanto evidentemente que isso tem um
custo e o custo do direito é o que
estamos a discutir aqui se nós temos
direito pela constituição cidadã como o
estado arcará com toda a gama de
serviços que a população brasileira
precisa
ao percorrermos hospitais percebemos que
isso não acontece ea constituição cidadã
aplica se de uma certa forma a quem tem
menos porque têm mais procura um plano
de saúde
ficamos nela esse dever prestacional é
fundado por tanto na ideia onde o estado
social o de um estado mínimo o estado
social é aquele que preconiza o
atendimento da sociedade da população a
partir de linhas de ação e de gestão
pública que sejam capazes de conferir ao
cidadão não só a segurança mas também o
atendimento que esse atendimento seja
eficaz e que o hospital embora simples
seja capaz de ter gaze equipamentos
médicos ou então nós estamos falando do
estado mínimo onde cada um terá um
atendimento mínimo indispensável para
não morrer e que cada um deverá tomar
conta de si mesmo contratando então um
plano de saúde se puder o sus
o atendimento a 180 milhões de pessoas e
no último balanço anual a a atendeu 2
bilhões e seiscentos mil atendimentos
entre consultas internações raios x
esse número estratosférico confere ao
ministério da saúde o maior orçamento
que a pasta ea esplanada dos ministérios
têm é o maior recurso público em um
único orçamento
no entanto isso não é a garantia para
nós é absolutamente nada nós brasileiros
estamos acostumados a conceber o estado
como ineficiente ineficaz
portanto mesmo com todo esse dinheiro a
saúde no brasil vai muito mal
o estado brasileiro é doente a quem é
doente
ainda dentro dessa classificação entre
doentes e saudáveis
uma outra concepção possível então a
partir desse raciocínio de que doentes
podem ser classificados entre os que têm
dinheiro recurso e os que não têm
para os que não têm recursos ou têm
poucos recursos não têm nenhum
o sistema universal garante atendimento
pelo menos é isso que a constituição
estabelece para os que tenham recursos e
conseguem pagar uma mensalidade por mês
ao plano de saúde e assim
concebemos a nós o nosso atendimento de
saúde a partir dessas premissas do do
maior sonho da população brasileira a
não ser a casa própria que é ter um
plano de saúde então diferentemente do
que disse no começo há a garantia de
saúde não passa pelo entendimento de que
o estado fará políticas públicas de
saneamento básico não será um problema
para nós
a garantia é de que possamos de alguma
forma ganhar algum dinheiro pra com
comprar um plano de saúde que atenda
aquilo que o estado não nos dá
e aí é interessante sistema complexo
brasileiro porque do mesmo modo como nós
temos dinheiro privado aplicado no
privado eo público no público nós também
temos o contrário e esses dois mundos se
interligam justamente por recursos por
dinheiro
vejam que quando quando a pessoa
contrata o plano de saúde e paga por mês
e têm direito portanto aquilo que o
contrato lhe confere
por vezes aquela operadora de plano
aquela seguradora não lhe dar aquilo que
ele precisa o que o médico receitou e
ele recorre ao poder judiciário poder
público para que o poder judiciário diga
que aquele contrato deve ser coberto
pelo plano de saúde
e aí instalar o judiciário sem nenhum
juízo de valor de certo e errado aqui
fique bem claro instalar o judiciário
fazendo justiça social aquela que a
constituição garante mas que o estado
brasileiro não consegue conferir com
recursos públicos
o recurso privado venceu com socorro do
cidadão mesmo que o seu contrato não lhe
garanta isso
de outro modo se esse segurado do plano
de saúde foi atropelado que na rua
espero que aqui não aconteça e que seja
socorrido pelo samu e levado ao hospital
ele será atendido pelo sistema único de
saúde que se ressarcir a depois por
aquilo que o plano dele deveria cumprir
e que por uma emergência não cobriu
então o dinheiro privado também vem pro
público de outro modo hospitais privados
são custeados pelo pela união e pelos
estados
então e pelos municípios então é
dinheiro público custeando serviços
privados ea realidade escancarada ainda
mais quando nós freqüentamos hospitais
para visitar alguém ou por mesmo porque
estamos doentes mesmo ilegal a separação
em aulas dos hospitais é muito nítida e
demonstra mais uma vez que doentes não
são só doentes doentes são doentes com
recursos ou sem com dinheiro ou sem nós
é muito comum em hospitais inteiros
terem aulas únicas exclusivamente que
atendem particulares chamada sala vip
hospitais que atendem ou num outro andar
um outro prédio o plano de saúde e um
outro prédio um outro andar com os
beneficiários do sistema único
por vezes até o médico que passa pelas
alas
é o mesmo o tipo de atendimento muito
parecido mas
o recurso que vem por trás disso é
extremamente diferenciado garantido uma
distensão que aquela analogia é bem
presente entre a praça eo jardim para
aqueles que estão na praça
há que se ter mais tempo há que se ter
paciência e ser mais simples com menos
conforto talvez algum atendimento mais -
presente para aqueles que estão no
jardim ao conforto ao café
a outra porta de entrada a 11 espera
menos representativa
será que efetivamente os custos são
compatíveis
fico pensando se aquilo que se passa se
paga pelo plano de saúde deve ser
realmente para custear esse tipo de
solução de mais conforto e mais - espera
de mais um café e talvez alguém que
possa lhe dar um pouco mais de atenção
esses dois mundos da praça do jardim pra
mim
soam sempre soaram desde que comecei a
estudar isso é muito muito inadmissíveis
ou pelo menos cuja luta tem que ser para
diminuir essa distinção então se nós
temos recursos públicos aplicados no
serviço privado se nós temos dinheiro
privado de operadoras de planos de
bancos e seguradoras devolvendo o poder
público porque não integramos em
entregar integrarmos esses dois mundos
de que forma nós podemos aproximar as
pessoas que são atendidas em hospitais
laboratórios postos de saúde com um
atendimento que tenha fundamento no
indivíduo então se eu comecei falando do
indivíduo
passei pelo estado porque afinal de
contas é o estado que garante a ele a
segurança
estou retornando a ele para entendê-lo
como a razão de ser
tanto do estado quanto dos operadores de
planos de saúde é certo que para os
executivos de grandes contratados
o lucro é fundamental para manter a
exigíveis o sistema e ea grande ameaça
que se operadoras quebrarem não tiverem
o que vai fazer com essas pessoas no sus
penso que a solução não é essa nem
imaginar que não há por que a opção a
gente precisa ter nem imaginar que a o
lucro desmedido em torno de um bem que é
coletivo
qual a solução eu não vim aqui por
soluções e nem para criar criticar o
sistema mas para dizer a vocês que a
reflexão deve passar pela proximidade do
jardim e da praça que a praça seja mais
acolhedora e que o jardim seja menos
excludente
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]